going to explain the Comstock Act
why Republicans want to revive it
and how it could diminish abortion access in the United States
so this is Anthony Comstock
he was known for being a village nuisance and a chronic casterbatur
in the late 1800s
Comstock became obsessed with being the morality police
he was against anything and everything that he viewed as being immoral
because he thought these immoralities were poisoning society
so he was against gambling
prostitution
birth control abortion
anything seggsually explicit
even nude art
no I'm digressing here a little bit
but like the people
even in the 1800s were just dragging Anthony Comstock
so like we got these unreal comics of him
so here he is
um being offended by mannequins
and here he's chasing a neked cat
see how the other cat has clothes on
and here the top right is my favorite
they're like
joking about how he probably bathes with his clothes on
eventually this weirdo goes to Congress
and explains that all of these immoralities are poisoning American society
and that he has an idea to stop it
that we should start monitoring materials
that are going through the US Postal Service
The Comstock Act was born
which banned certain materials
obscene materials passing through the US Postal Service
that are intended for the prevention of conceptions
like birth control or procuring of abortion
somehow gets Congress to agree to make him a special agent of the Postal Service
with police level powers
including the right to a weapon
so he starts going around personally inspecting the mail
he personally seized and destroyed 15 tons of books
4 million pictures
and claimed that books are feeders for brothels
one of his victims was idecratic
who ended up unaliving herself before being sent to federal prison
and and her on a living note
specifically condemned Comstock
do you think it's bad for somebody to blame you and their
on a living note oh no
of his 4,000 arrests
14 other people said that he specifically drove them to doing that
naturally 150 years later
Republicans would like to revive this man's work
thing is that the Comstock Act is still a law
it was never explicitly repealed
it's just over the last 150 years
it kind of just went into oblivion and became obsolete
as it should until now
Republicans wanna bring back the enforcement of the construct act
because they're saying
we already have a law in the books that prohibits mailing of abortion pills
beauty of this for them
is that they don't need to get the votes and Congress to pass a law this crazy
it's already on the books
they would need
as a Republican president
who would lead an administration
namely the department of justice
that would be amenable and open to enforcing this act
already making these arguments
so in the mifipristone case
coming for the Supreme Court this term
anti choice activists are already making arguments
that mailing mifipristone in the mail violates the Comstock Act
upheld in court
it would not only outlaw medication abortion
which is the most common form of abortion
so hoping to use it to stop surgical abortions
by pointing to language in the act
saying that it bans any article or thing designed
adapted or intended for producing abortion
so they're trying to say that you also can't mail any medical equipment
that would be used to procure an abortion
far from a slam dunk
as you're probably anticipating
there are so many legal hurdles with trying to enforce a law like this
for now I'm gonna pause
if you want me to talk about those legal hurdles
let me know in the comments
and let me know what you think